[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
doors I first think of it Dear John and
Hank it's a comedy podcast where two
brothers answer your question to give
EDB us advice and bring you all the
week's news from both Mars and AFC
Wimbledon how you doin John I'm doing so
well Hank
I mostly for reasons that we can't talk
about until the end of the podcast I
have to confess that I am a little bit
limping to the finish line of 2017 it
has been a pretty long year for me I
published my first book in six years it
would that was pretty stressful exciting
but stressful lots of things have been
happening movie stuff like just a lot a
lot of and I had labyrinthitis which I
don't recommend despite it's
metaphorically resonant name it's just
been the last couple months have been a
little intense so I am I am just trying
to just trying to get to the end and
move on to 2018 how are you I'm good I
just have a baby and it's so good I am I
also really really want to see the Star
Wars movie I want to see yeah but I
can't cuz like how do parents ever watch
movies how does it you have a babysitter
get a babysitter I get I guess but I
feel like I've been getting a babysitter
I should be like doing something where
Catherine and I hang out not just know
something together no it's ridiculous no
go see the Star Wars movie it's a lovely
I still I still love a good movie as a
date night I think movies continue to be
a great date night you know what movies
gonna be a great date night Hank what
movie turtles all the way down coming to
a theater near you oh goodness I okay
John who do you want to babysit my baby
well I will go watch the Star Wars movie
yeah that's a good idea I want to spend
12 hours flying to Missoula so I can
spend three hours with my nephew no I
don't you want a short poem okay
all right the short poem was sent in by
Heather it's very good and it's about
death so Thank You Heather for sharing a
poem about
death I appreciate it it's by Maurya sin
sin yon whose name I'm sure I'm
mispronouncing and it is translated from
Japanese bury me when I die
beneath a wine barrel in a tavern with
luck the cask will leak ah it's good
Hank it's good I would love to have just
a few glasses of wine after my death but
I feel that the odds are against me
John our first question of your Hank and
John comes from Milton who asks dear
Hank and John ah help I have a final on
birds in less than two hours I have to
memorize all the birds orders family and
species of California and in two hours I
have to put all that knowledge to a test
please help please send help with the
atomic number of 50 tin like tin yeah no
TI in it it does have the atomic number
of 50 Hank do you know where the
elements get their atomic numbers from I
thought this was just a fascinating fact
ah yes where do they get their numbers
from the number of protons they have ah
see I always thought it was from just a
dartboard that like chemists would throw
a dart at a dartboard and they'd be like
50 tin but no it turns out it's the
number of protons they have well there's
a certain amount of logic to just like
Oh will this is the lightest one and so
it's number one and this is the second
lightest one so it's number two it will
just order them by by weight and that is
how they are ordered but it just happens
that's that sort of also a consequence
of the fact that protons are where a lot
of the mass of an atom comes from and as
you increase protons you also increase
neutrons which is the other place that
the mass of the atom comes from but that
is neither here nor there John that's
chemistry and we have a problem with
regards to bird taxonomy apparently yeah
it's a little weird to me taxonomy bird
taxonomy feels a little bit dated as a
thing that you should have to memorize
to me maybe tin is writing from the
distant past like 1964 yeah I'm like
what is what is gonna help you by how
are you going to be assisted by knowing
all of the order family and species of
all birds in California
that is a huge like I got like
California's a big and diverse place
it's got mountains it's got its got like
cold it's got hot it's got my you simha
tea and it's got all of the things it's
would you like to take a guess how many
bird species there are in California go
with I'm gonna go with 500-600
that I was remarkably close actually
yeah I mean how well I wouldn't have
been within an order of magnitude I
would have said 12
I thought we'd eliminated most of the
nonhuman species but apparently a few of
them are still going strong um you know
what the official state bird of
California is I bet tin does the herring
gull John it's the herring gull no it's
the Condor the California condor must be
nope it's the California quail that's
terrible
you got a look at a picture of
California quail Hank they've got one of
those headdresses that makes them look a
little bit like Napoleon they look like
bird Napoleon I can't look at al and so
I've just googled the California quali
well the California quail also is
excellent but the California quail I
mean to be fair the Condor is a
wonderful bird very majestic but I have
never seen a bird that is so clearly
suited to official state dimas' the
California quail I mean the California
quail might be the next governor of
California a California quail looks as
if it is tipping its hat to you all of
the time it does it hello sir hello um
hello BAM hello madam hello
so tin this is a dumb assignment and we
disagree with it that is our that is our
take we do not like this as an
assignment we think you should be
learning about why tins atomic number is
50 not about all of the geniuses and
species and orders of birds in
California but I do want to say Hank
yeah I have a buddy who is an
ornithologist mm-hmm I that's just
something I wanted to say because I very
rarely find myself in a situation where
I get to talk about my friend who's an
ornithologist oh well yeah maybe we
should talk to him about why why why not
this is important though I could
probably talk real quick with my my
friend who's a professor of turtle
studies and asked him would he
about this and if you'd be interested in
that I do all right
it's dr. turtleman available hey dr.
turtleman hello hey how's it going yeah
we've got so we've got somebody who's
needs to learn a bunch of species and
orders and families of birds in
California is that oh that's oh come on
really they're still doing that
that's ridiculous uh yeah what do you
got it no it's not it's not like all of
the different species and genus it's
it's that these things are related in
how they're related understanding the
connection between organisms is much
more valuable than understand like being
able to name the genus and order of
family and species of all the birds of
California come on teachers there you go
dr. turtleman everybody just when I
thought he'd retired our next question
comes from Talia or possibly Talia who
asks Dear John and Hank two weeks ago I
got very sick and I ended up in the
hospital I'm very sorry to hear about
that telling ya I'm a college student
and now I'm left with a bill I can't
afford oh my god this is even after the
hospital cut my bill by more than 50%
right but it was it was cut by more than
50% from like tens of thousands of
dollars whereas if you'd gotten sick
anywhere else in the world I assumed
that your american talia because this
isn't a problem for college students
usually outside of America although it
is occasionally Oh God anyway what do
you do when you can't pay for something
that you have to pay for tell yeah I
mean usually you sign up for a payment
plan John sorry is just opening a diet
dr. pepper I don't know if you heard
that but that's the sound of me feeling
despondent yeah I'm only one real
response which is go get yourself a
six-pack a crisp diet dr. pepper not yet
a sponsor of this podcast it'll solve
all your problems Talia no yeah I mean
usually you get in touch with the
hospital and you see if you can work out
a payment plan over a long period of
time another option in some cases is to
file for bankruptcy if you don't have a
lot
assets it may make sense to file for
bankruptcy although that comes with its
own set of problems I'm I just wanted to
read this question mostly because I want
to make the point that I believe very
strongly that it is really bad for our
economy and for our social order to even
have the possibility that a college
student can be left with a bill that
they cannot afford it is bad it is bad
economically it is bad policy it is bad
social policy it makes our lives as
Americans worse period yeah Minh dove
makes living in this country a little
bit of a gamble what I mean I know that
like all life is a gamble and that
things like bad things are gonna happen
but but eliminating those uncertainties
is such a valuable thing for you know
mental health but also the economy like
allowing rebel to take the risks to do
interesting things and to you know try
to make their own business that may end
up then having its own employees and I
it feels very strange to you know
sometimes know that I have to compete
with companies that don't have to pay
for their employees health insurance and
it's just like hah that must be easier
in a lot of ways for you to not have to
deal with that right but also it's in
the best interest of our country and our
economy to have Tahlia focusing on her
studies so that she can become a better
educated person and you know be
productive in not just the labor market
but also in bringing new and interesting
ideas into the world instead of having
to stress out about paying her medical
bills it should not be a thing that
exists and we know that it doesn't have
to exist because in a lot of the world
it doesn't this next question comes from
Lena who asks dear Hank and John how do
you eat trail mix am I supposed to stuff
my face with a handful of it at all at
once or do I eat each piece one by one
nuts and pretzels Lena are you what what
what it doesn't make any sense yeah you
fill your whole hand up Lena and then
you put that whole handful in your mouth
and that's the whole great
thing about trail mixes that you get all
the different flavors all at once you
get the little slight sweetness of the
raisins and the crunchy salty of the
nuts but you also get the crunchy very
sweet of the peanut peanuts peanut
butter peanut heaven what am i happening
of the eminence I I have to say Hank I
feel like there's been a few occasions
most of them have probably been cut out
of the podcast by Nick but I think
they've been a few occasions today where
something went wrong with your circuitry
and just like as almost like you had to
like reboot it's been a very long week
it continues to be and I meant to eat a
balanced bar sometime in the last four
hours and I just haven't yeah that also
contributes to my having to reboot
periodically I this is what I want to
say to Lena Lena when I first started
dating the woman who is now my wife I
remember we went out to see a movie it
was called lost in translation
and we sat next to each other as you do
when you're on a first date or usually
and we sat next to each other and I had
ordered a large popcorn because that's
what I like to eat at the movies and and
Sarah asked if she could have a some of
my popcorn and I said yeah of course not
because I actually think it's okay for
someone to take part of my large popcorn
because I strongly strongly dislike it
when someone takes any of my large
popcorn but because you know as a first
date I was trying to impress her these
days if anybody else they can have a
part of my large popcorn no get your own
popcorn I didn't order this for you this
is my popcorn and yes it comes with a
free refill but that's my free refill
anyway back to my story so Sarah reaches
over into the popcorn bucket and pulls
out a single piece of popcorn and then
puts a single piece of popcorn in her
mouth and Hank I could not have been
more surprised if she had grown a second
head it's good it's like putting water
in your cereal it's so weird that's not
fair
when I see someone eat a sigle Pete like
when I finish a large popcorn like and I
stand up at the end of the movie it
looks like there
been a massacre it looks like there was
the Spartan pop chords version pop
chords and they have a bolt like there
was it there was a chicane yes there are
a million bands yes yeah and I know that
that's terrible
I I didn't always throw away my all my
stuff I know that like it makes it hard
for movie theater employees but I cannot
I eat popcorn a handful at a time I eat
trail mix a handful at a time I of
course you want as much food in your
mouth as possible at any given moment
John did she then later take a second
piece of popcorn or did you just go
correct okay so it wasn't like I will
have this one thank you very much and
then she was like I felt the wave of
animosity coming off of this man who no
I thought it will be okay for me to ask
her is popcorn but clearly it wasn't no
not at all no it was just it was a pure
like she still like she still she'll get
a popcorn when we go to the movies and
she'll eat it one piece at a time like I
mean it's like what do you want another
best popcorn related thing that ever
happened to me so I once went to so I
once went to the movies with one of our
cousins and he got a popcorn and a box
of M&Ms and we sat down and this was the
coolest thing that had ever happened to
me I was like I was probably like 15
years old and he's like older than us
and he got set down his popcorn open up
his M&Ms and just poured the M&Ms into
the popcorn
oh yeah oh it's so cool I was like oh my
god it's so good it's so good it's like
making your own trail mix oh it really
is it's way worse for you ah I mean I
don't know about that just think about
trail mix is that ostensibly you're
eating it while walking with popcorn
Eminem combo you're eating it while
reclining yeah trail mix us like that
like like if popcorn and M&Ms was was
was like sort of a normal trail food
then it would be fine because the point
of trail mix is that there's a lot of
food in it and it's easier to eat
whereas the point of the point of
popcorn M&M
is not that like it's not like you need
a lot of fuel for this three hour movie
going experience gar I think our next
question comes from Hanna who writes
Dear John and Hank my sisters python
escaped several days ago and she just
fed it so it's not even hungry uh well
okay okay mmm it's I would probably
prefer a not hungry Python all face
being equal yeah so it's not even hungry
that's good news that it's not hungry
it's such a bummer we don't have a
hungry escaped snake in the house yeah
if only if only the Python was hungry
then it would reveal itself while
strangling one of us to death I'm coming
home from the crisp for Christmas break
very soon in my room hasn't had any way
very soon
wait weeks okay wait okay the pythons
how much do python eat do they eat like
once every six months
how often do path ons
eat um 10 to 14 days okay all right yeah
all right so my room is the perfect
quiet place for it to hide out how am I
gonna sleep at night how do I prevent
its slithering next to me for heat its
that okay if that's the main concern
like I'm thought like I like if it's
just cuddle time I mean I'm in I'm in
for a snake cuddle time I don't but I
want to like wake up with a no no no no
I do not want to wake up out of a deep
sleep to learn that there is a snake
cuddled next to me hard stop I mean okay
all right I agree I just think that it's
not the worst possible outcome uh well I
mean I guess it's not the worst possible
outcome because the worst possible
outcome is always death but like it's a
very bad outcome Hannah there's an
obvious solution here which is that this
is not your Python this is not your
problem
and this was not your mistake so you
come home for the Christmas holidays and
the first words out of your mouth are
hello sister I will be sleeping in your
room until the Python is recovered yeah
what I need from you what I need from
you is
when I arrived home all of my furniture
is out of the room there is nothing
nothing in the room and so I can see its
Python freeness delete lack of Python
'ti and then I can move all of the
furniture back in one at a time you
reintroduce things into your room I Hank
I think we've solved the problem
unfortunately Hannah's already home in
real life and so she's probably already
been strangled to death by her sister's
Python sorry about that Hannah wish we'd
gotten to your question earlier but you
know so it goes hey it's okay it's okay
to have a cuddle I just don't like I've
met people who've gotten constrictors
slashed on their hands before and it
sounds like it's real not good Oh God ah
next question comes from Anika who asks
dear Hank and John I have a dilemma I
want to try to get information on
current events from a variety of sources
I currently use BBC and The Economist
for my main news sources making you more
better at this then literally everyone
however in a recent conversation with a
friend she pointed out that both of
those sources are fairly liberal I like
to use moderate and more conservative
sources as well and hopes to get a
fuller picture of the Economist is a
little girl in what world is the
Economist which I believe endorsed both
Ronald Reagan and George W Bush a
liberal magazine I don't know it's so we
like the Economist was in favor of
American intervention into Vietnam and
into Iraq The Economist is in
extraordinarily in my opinion moderate
news source like I think they I think
they endorsed Hillary Clinton in 2016
but doc I thought I I think the
Economist is a very very
middle-of-the-road news source and it
would only be considered like a liberal
rag in my mind I also it doesn't really
fall along the lines of like totally
along the lines of contemporary liberal
conservative bias because its bias is is
pretty strongly toward free markets
which it used to be a conservative thing
and now seems to be a thing that doesn't
neatly
all on a liberal or conservative thing
yeah I feel like you're doing okay yeah
Anika's problem is that the only
conservative news should know sir she
knows about is Fox News and I have some
problems with them yeah I actually I
would recommend use that isn't kind of
aggressively partisan and always
constantly trying to frame every news
story around you know a left-right axis
I would read The Wall Street Journal I
think The Wall Street Journal is a
pretty consistently conservative paper
at least in its editorial column and
it's pretty in general not always but in
general you know well reported stories
so I that's what I read but I think
you're doing ok with the BBC in the
Economist you're doing better than most
of us I mean most of us and I'm not and
I'm guilty of this as much as anyone do
nothing but read like the opinion pages
at blah blah blah calm slash opinion
yeah I mean most to be very honest most
of what I read is the headlines on
Twitter so that's all God
I'm one of them and the great thing is
we tweet the headline on Twitter because
it's enraging yeah well I do I do try to
read a little bit of the artifact I'm
gonna retweet it first but but I will
say that there have been studies done
that we tend not to do that as as as a
rule so probably I do that as well yeah
I mean in in limping to the finish line
of 2017 Hank I have to tell you that
part of what I'm thinking about is what
my 2018 is going to look like in terms
of my relationship to the social
Internet because just I mmm sorry I had
another hard reset there I I have such
mixed feelings mm-hmm it's a hard one
for me I love the dopamine rush of the
social Internet and also it's a big part
of my professional life but at the same
time I think it might be really bad for
my brain yeah I think that it is
it may be and it is very hard to use it
in a constructive way I'm trying to do
that more by asking myself how Mister
Rogers would tweet and and that is is
rewarding to some extent but alright
okay but I want to read some of your
recent tweets to you just real quick if
I made just from the last you know what
hey let's just the last 24 hours
okay all right I'm gonna check out what
I've what I've said okay um can anyone
build a web page very quickly that
auto-updates from the individual API the
person who donated that was recently in
what perk they got like by Friday
that doesn't seem like something mr.
Roger Stokes we did like I don't think
mr. Rogers had access to any of those
ideas well maybe if mr. Rogers was
running a charity campaign he needed
something to help him out real quick
let's go a little bit further back
because Hank has tweeted a lot in the
last 24 hours which also I would submit
is not something mr. Rogers would have
done it's not it's not surprising that
more hasn't conceded his campaign was
based on the idea that he is the only
credible institution in the country what
that's not something mr. Rogers would
have tweeted people in power pushing the
fake news narrative have nothing to lose
from continuing to question every
institution outside themselves again I'm
not convinced mr. Rogers that we did
that no let's go back let's go back to
20 hours ago I agree and that was about
that was the one I knew you were gonna
pick two I was like what I tweeted it I
was like this and routers wouldn't tweet
this but that I did it anyway okay
earlier yesterday
you tweeted okay Hank here's another
example of a tweet that you tweeted very
recently that I don't think mr. Rogers
would have tweeted quote my mom just now
so very long pause what is a furry
[Music]
yeah I don't yeah I feel like maybe mr.
routers wouldn't have tweeted that but
he might have tweeted the update tweet
which was update my mom is excited that
furries are living their best lives and
hopes that the pressures of the world
aren't getting to them too much Hank I
do not know of a Twitter feed I mean
actually I do I was gonna say I don't
know of a Twitter feed that less
resembles what mr. Rogers tweets would
look like but of course I do know um
yeah most of them hi yeah hi so much my
argument would be that I think mr.
Rogers might not be tweeting if it was
that he was around in this particular
timeline at this particular moment he'd
be like I think I'm not gonna engage in
that way
yeah because like I I think engaging in
that way kind of comes with tweets that
Mister Rogers wouldn't tweet let's say
let's move on to another question this
one comes from Abigail who writes Dear
John and Hank after a recruiter came to
my school I've seriously considered
going into the US Navy many people have
told me that I can't do it because I'm
only five feet tall and I've never
really worked out a day in my life but
I'm very determined to succeed in this
endeavor I've started running and doing
sit-ups and push-ups my mom isn't fond
of this idea as most mothers wouldn't be
she would rather me do two years of
Community College and then decide from
there I'm 18 so I could usurp her and
enlist on my own
but I really want her approval on this
life choice because you know it's a big
one any dubious advice is greatly
appreciated not the root beer Abigail
Whitcomb that's a that's a and W ha
those are you paying attention at huh
Hank this is exciting because we get to
decide if somebody goes into the Navy if
anybody should be given that power it
should be me
first of all I'll say that I don't know
that there are physical requirements
that you like that they won't take a
person under a certain height a lot of
what is done in the Navy is work that
doesn't necessarily require a lot of
physicality I have several friends who
are in the Navy who are not big strong
people but I think that your mom is the
is the more interesting part of this
question and yeah maybe friends who are
like maybe maybe not do that
it's it it's a big ask it is a thing
that it is a big commitment and it is a
a commitment to something that you won't
know if you like until you're there and
that that is that is what it is yeah I'm
gonna go ahead and just say but do it
Abigail join the Navy no I'm just
kidding don't listen to podcasters about
whether or not to join the Navy make
that decision with your mom I understand
that you could enlist on your own but I
also don't know that it will negatively
impact your career to have two years of
Community College before you enlist in
the Navy in fact it might be good for
for your career and then even if you end
up having your whole career in the Navy
you know a 20-year career that would put
you at 40 when you retire from the Navy
which isn't ha that old I know it seems
only right now I remember being 18 it
seemed like 40 was forever away but let
me tell you it arrives before you know
it there's also separate kinds of being
in the military there's officer school
which is a very different track from
just enlisting and that might be
something that if you had a couple years
of Community College might be an option
more all open to you and that comes with
a bunch of perks perks and and options
that you don't necessarily have a few
just enlist that said Abigail you've
come to the worst possible pod I get to
get advice on a military career yeah
there are there are probably some out
there that actually have some experience
whereas John and I have less than none
yeah I mean we have a couple cousins who
are in the Navy that's as close as we
get and actually they're both out now so
that yeah nope we have do we have no
experience today's podcast is brought to
you by the United States Navy the United
States Navy not a subject of expertise
for the green brothers this podcast is
also brought to you by limping to the
end of 2017 just we'll get there
we can do it and today's podcast is also
brought to you by snake cuddles snake
cuddles avoid them good
I don't know if I'm not surprised by
that might be into it I've been doing
some snake cuddles I just don't want to
wake up in have snake cuddles be
happening to me this podcast is
additionally brought to you by M&Ms and
popcorn mixed together inside of my
popcorn bucket and my mouth it's the
best and maybe you'll be a little bit
more careful to not drop any on the
floor to create the battle field of of
lost boss popcorn souls alright that
went on longer than I think any of us
expected we also have a real sponsor
today our real sponsor today is story
blocks which is a fun sponsor for us to
have because it's something that Hank
and I both use a lot and really believe
in you can go to story blocks comm slash
dear Hank and John to learn more that
story blocks capital S lowercase B story
blocks allows anybody to have access to
lots and lots of stock footage it's
really an incredible tool if you whether
you make websites or you make youtube
videos like we do it just has a huge
library and it's very affordable yeah so
uh they have audio they have video they
have images and each of those is its own
separate subscription service usually
but the offer here is that you get all
of those for the price of just one of
them and that comes with a subject that
the stuff that comes with the
subscription and I sort of labeled
separately and you can see those those
images really easily that like the
membership images and in video but then
there's also stuff that you that are
being submitted from outside of the
story of lock system and and you will be
you basically pay the creator of that
stuff directly and this is a good thing
because then artists can pay artists for
the use of their art and then
everybody's art gets better and it's
good and I like it and their the the
prices for those things that are outside
of the member library the marketplace
things are are not included in the in
the member library but and they're the
prices for those things vary but the
member library is really big in robust
and has a ton of
stuff and we use it pretty frequently
when making things for all of the things
that we make both the scishow crash
course but also vlogbrothers when we're
doing it directly so I've had a story
block subscription for a couple of years
now I got it after I found out about it
from an advertisement on a podcast so
boom there you go
story blocks comm slash dear Hank and
John thanks for sponsoring today's
podcast and you can get that triple
bundle that's images video and audio all
for the price of one it's $149 a year
and at least for us a really really good
deal yeah one-stop shop for all your
stock media needs story voxcom slash
dear Hank and John dari I think I want
to answer another question from our
listeners alright John I wanna I want to
answer to that to this one comes from
Helen who writes dear John and Hank I'm
a first-year University student and I
have two friends I love my friends and I
feel very grateful to have gotten to
know such nice and genuine people so
early on in my college experience
however I've come across a huge problem
and a threat to this sense of security I
have in these friendships to my dismay
recently both of them have separately
confided in me that they have feelings
for the other is the problem or is it
how am I suddenly stuck in a teen
rom-com where I haven't want so much
power of information and yet feel so
powerless against the forces of my
friend's love for each other should I
tell them how the other feels should I
see how long this takes to play out and
stay out of it mostly I'm worried that I
will lose both of them if their
impending relationship either fails or I
become an eternal third wheel should I
find new friends dubious advice needed
Helen all right Helen I got a great idea
okay what is it so you're gonna take
your friends and you're gonna go on a
fun little adventure just like go
someplace what did you have to drive to
and then get that like I don't know just
a playground in a nearby town hang out
there do the things that you like to do
and then be like oh I got to go and
drive away and leave them there I mean
that would have been like a kind of like
a funny rom-com I
in 1997 pre uber but now they would just
be like three minutes behind you okay
okay
Jane pick me up in the Toyota Tercel and
we're coming back we'll be at the dorm
three minutes later so this is even
better this is better it's better for
all kinds of reasons you get the uber
and leave your car sale I'm going to
leave the car since you guys can come
home I'll just get an uber home cuz I
got a my my Python is really hungry and
slash the tires of the car so they have
to stay with the car but they can't
leave oh yeah that's a that's a really
good way to ensure that your friendship
doesn't get ruined by this new
relationship let's get a nail in there
and they'll be like oh it's a male and
then they have oh yeah resort to
subterfuge yes that's a great plan no
that's a terrible idea Hank Helen
here's the thing man this is actually a
really obvious situation your friends
don't actually have feelings for each
other
they're testing you they agreed to
pretend to have feelings for each other
and to go to you separately to see how
you would react it's a bit yeah you up
to reverse prank the prank you've got a
reverse prank the prank so what you need
to do is you need to go to your friend
let's say your friends are named Joey
and Bob you need to go to Joey and you
need to say Joey Bob told me something
very very serious he told me that no
backup Hank let's say your friends are
named Joey and Chandler you need to go
to Joey and you say Joey I have the most
amazing news Chandler has feelings for
you and then you go to Chandler and you
say Chandler I have the most amazing
news I am in love with you that way
you've got a full friend situation right
a probably love triangle way better yeah
cuz this isn't even a love triangle this
is it's not it's this is a love line
it's that it's not even a plot Helen
yeah I mean I still so so what's the
most romantic thing you can think of
John what's the most romantic situation
you can get in with you your friends you
go shop
for a fish that's very romantic I had a
fish store and then and then but you
only have enough money for one fish but
then you realize as you're leaving that
you don't that you don't need the fish
so you give them the fish and then they
have a shared fish and it's basically
like being married right that's how love
blossoms I have a couple problems with
that strategy as well I you don't like
any of my ideas well I've got okay so
let's let's take a the bold choice here
I think is for Helen to go to both Joey
and Chandler and say you guys are
crushing on each other and I think you
should pursue this but I need to stay
your friend no matter what no that's not
good I think all right
the reason I'm sympathetic to this
problem Hank is that I definitely had
this happen to me a bunch of times in
college
like one time I was on a road trip with
my two best friends to the Grand Canyon
and we would like sleep in like $30 a
night hotels and then eventually like I
realized that they like one afternoon I
like saw them kissing at the Grand
Canyon and I was like oh yeah now that
explains why like I'm in one hotel room
and they're like they're in the other I
see what's the actual thing you do is
like you pick one of them and you say
I'm pretty sure that if you go for it
it'll work out right right because the
next time they Joey comes to you and
says like I really have feelings for
Chandler you can just say listen I'm not
positive but I suspect that if you talk
to Chandler about this Chandler's gonna
recipie we should go to the fete to the
to the fish store and then then it's a
date and it's it's going it's moving
that's not a date yeah that's not a date
I have a weird you have a weird
definition of dates you wanna what are
your first dates with Sara was to target
it was very romantic see and this is
better because there's fish I think they
have fish at Target actually not a my
target you know maybe maybe it's maybe
only on fish at Walmart anyways I'm not
sure we feel about aquarium fish I don't
want to get in
with the anti aquarium fish people they
do have fish fingers set target all
right so now we're just in trouble with
the vegans like answer one more question
from our listeners before we get to the
incredible news from AFC Wimbledon I
mean oh god alright I'm so excited all
right Hank
yeah it's your turn to ask a question
you asked it is this final question John
comes from Sarah who asks dear Hank and
John when we say it's raining what is it
mmm yeah yeah that's that's what
upsetting thought to me I mean it's just
the experience that I am inside of like
the the bubble of reality that I sort of
consider to be applicable to me at the
moment is that it well I mean here's the
thing Hank like what does it mean to be
like it is midnight
what is midnight time it is the thing
that I am in right it's that it's my
entire conception of my world that is
applicable to me it is midnight it oh
man it yeah I just don't think it means
anything I think that's my thing no
because you could just it's just a way
of saying raining but if you just say
raining doesn't feel like a sentence
raining yeah you do you do need to sit
and sentence and so you need a you need
a thing and you need a verb and you need
an adjective and so so you needed what
we need the adjective to apply to
something and that is it but I think
actually there seems to be a phrase for
this it's called a dummy pronoun oh yeah
it's just a grammatical construct of
English is what I'm reading which
requires that a sentence have a subject
so if you didn't need a subject for the
sentence you could just say raining but
since you need a subject for the
sentence of some kind you have to say it
is rain
and the thing that's raining is right
just like you said like the universe
around you like the your world in your
world it is raining just as in your
world it is midnight or in your world
the sun is shining or this makes it is
sunny this makes me think is there an
amount of like individuality that is
that is based on linguistics like
knowing that that like an occurrence has
to be happening to a thing and that
thing is this dummy pronoun it but that
it has to do with the world as I
perceive it yes that affect how I see
the world
Oh totally so Hank you may be familiar
with the hot new book turtles all the
way down it's actually been number one
on the New York Times bestseller list
for eight consecutive weeks mm-hmm it is
that actual book and not a construct
correct it's it is not a dummy pronoun
it is a book but I kind of wrote that
book in the wake of this sort of
extended period in which I felt that I
was not a like a singular noun and I
felt like all of the definitions that
had been provided to me of self were
completely inadequate in the face of my
own experience with like the
relationship between like consciousness
and language and the relationship
between what people were calling myself
and the things that my self was supposed
to be or be able to do and I I mean like
my conclusion coming out of that period
which is a little bit what the book is
about but mostly just like my personal
conclusion coming out of that period is
that thought and self and like
constructing self there's no way you can
really construct self separate from
thought and there's no way you can
really in my opinion anyway if in my
experience no way I can construct
thought separate from language like I
can't I can't find a way into myself
that makes sense
except via language so it is raining is
like a reflection to me of like the
self nests of my experience it there
where is it it's there it's here it's
it's within it's it's it's in me it is
in me okay now it got weird Hank do you
want to go do you want to say the news
from Mars first or can I say the news
from AFC Wiggly yeah I'll give you some
quick news from Mars so right now as of
as of when we're recording this podcast
a different temperature differentials
have spawned dust storm at Mars is North
Pole dust storms are a thing that
happened fairly frequently on Mars but
occasionally they will have there there
will be these gigantic like sort of
planet-wide dust storms that can last
for a very long time
you know like hundreds of days on the
order of and we actually haven't had
those for a while and that's very good
because these dust storms blow a lot of
dust around which can get into the
equipment of our Rovers it can also
block out the Sun so the rivers that are
powered by solar panels have a harder
time functioning so it's nice that we
have had a break in large dust storms
but it's possible that as since you know
it has been a while since we've had one
that another one is sort of on the way
and maybe even forming right now so
there's big old dust storm and and
hopefully well it will not be one that
effects too much of the areas where we
have our Rovers that's what's happened
in on Mars right now John I oh I really
hope that the Martian weather stays good
for our Rovers that would be tell it's
so hard I mean think about working for
NASA in this situation it seems to me is
that you control for all the variables
you can but the stakes are so high and
you can never control for all the
variables yeah
yeah and and like that that's crazy that
like weather is one of them because of
course we are aware of of like when we
plan a wedding we're like well we should
probably have a place where we could do
it indoors if we have to right yeah you
cannot eat when you have like every
three to four years there's a global
Martian dust storm that will impact the
ability to do the mission
that's you know three or four years is
you know like the life of the Curiosity
rover so far so right it's nice that
we've had this little dust storm drought
ya know thank goodness for dust storm
droughts well Hank the news from AFC
Wimbledon I have to say it's just
incredibly exciting which is that
earlier today as we are recording this
it was announced it's all over the
English newspapers that AFC Wimbledon
have been given final permission to
build their new stadium at plough Lane
returning to their historic homeland as
you know Hank for the last 25 years
Wimbledon fans have been singing this
song show me the way to plough Lane I'm
tired and I want to go home I had a
football ground 20 years ago and I want
one of my own and today they got final
final approval to build that Stadium to
go home and it is an incredible moment
for this club the stadium is going to
seat between 11 and 20,000 people I
think 11,000 people to start but it can
be expanded to hold up to 20,000 people
which would probably be enough to
support a Premier League club I'm just
saying and it's it's a really wonderful
moment the construction will begin
fairly soon now that now that they've
been given final permission it is a 25
million dollar project that's a lot of
money a lot of that money has been
raised a lot hasn't and but it they're
hoping that this will be done the new
stadium will be finished in time to play
the 2019 2020 season at Wimbledon back
in Wimbledon back at their spiritual
home it's just an amazing story of what
fans can do when they come together
well congratulations John that's very
exciting and and it just seems like
things are going good for AFC Wimbledon
right now even even though you guys are
still pretty far down at the bottom of
the table yeah I mean for the for the
like long-term health of the club and
for the long-term well-being of the club
this stadium is such a big deal because
it allows you know it allows the club to
be to have the kind of budget that you
need to be in Ligue 1 or the
championship because you know they won't
have the smallest stadium in the
football league anymore as they
currently do but yeah it's definitely
it's gonna be a difficult season I mean
20 games into a 46 game season and only
one spot above the relegation places is
definitely nerve-wracking but I am
hopeful I really am not least because
we've got that Tottenham money coming in
from the third round of the FA Cup all
right John what did we learn today on
this episode of dear Hank and John we
learned that Hank is weirdly unafraid of
snake cuddling and we learned that there
are 600 species of birds in California
and also we learned that the California
quail is not just California state bird
but also maybe California's next
governor and finally we learned that
Sara eats popcorn one popcorn at a time
and also I now just also learned that
the plural of popcorn is apparently
popcorn
done I didn't know that now there you go
oh well Hank thank you for potting with
me thanks to everybody for listening I
hope it's been a good 2017 for you even
if it hasn't necessarily been the best
year in a macro sense I hope it's been a
good year for you and thanks to
everybody again for listening and you
know pretty soon I'm gonna be reaching
out to everybody asking them for several
million dollars for this AFC Wimbledon
stadium project so if you are a
billionaire out there listening to your
Hank and John I've got a good place
where your money can go without it
saving any lives or curing any diseases
all right the podcast is produced by
rosianna halse rojas and shared and
Gibson it's edited by nicholas jenkins
our head of community and communications
is Victoria bon giorno the music that
you're hearing right now and at the
beginning of the episode and also at the
beginning of this week in Ryan's our
podcast about Ryan's that's available
only to our patreon patrons we really
thank you to our patreon patrons we'll
put some pictures of the California
quail up there is by the great
gunnarolla and as they say in our
hometown don't forget to be awesome
[Music]